uh-huh what's the matter cutie pie well
ever since you lost your legs I have no
one to react with what about me I have a
critter challenge for you PewDiePie
where are you I love you
kiss these plush show yourself boy
[Music]
how did you know my favorite thing these
things are practically free viewers how
you want to hit that you want to hit
that vape gab oh hell yeah I'm smoke on
a pop there you go let me hit you up
[Music]
TV reporter accidentally ruins martial
arts master demo I'm gonna break that
concrete slab with that glass without
breaking the glass without breaking the
glass let's go I'm excited for this this
is gonna be good come on how is he gonna
do that how that's dangerous don't do it
Gabba whoa wait night to be honest I
actually felt these bricks these are
real bricks I mean there's there's no
thanks Oh check it out baby guns
[Music]
oh the handshake
give me a replay like [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
it hurts this is why I love you double
cuz you don't have any [ __ ] hands
there's no way we can hang on to the
next cringe video Pharrell stops
functioning for 20 seconds and it's
awkward the frequencies that are
generated within atoms are far more
accurate than anything earth and the Sun
and the moon ever dreamt of doing and
that so now we use its atomic clock and
we can and you want to have ten o'clock
is really based on like atoms oh yeah so
now you bring them to walk into space
and you don't you no longer have to
adapt exactly
oh it's actually based on electrons she
keeps going huh this would be precise
Carol stop I don't know what frequency
that is just [ __ ] stop walk into
space and you don't you no longer have
to adapt exactly
it's actually based on electrons moving
within the atoms just to be precise I
don't know what frequency that is well
we managed to fund find someone more
unfunny than me how about that for Al
Pharrell everyone maybe he should just
stick to his music woman takes creep
shot of guy's junk look at her she looks
so guilty
oh yeah Oh
look at her she looks so guilty leaps
casual person ever seen she made eye
contact with a camera
Oh what phones Oh
how do they work let me see that [ __ ]
again that was beautiful
[Music]
so cute in this shot this a great shot
okay Kevin Kevin grab Bill Clinton
denied a kiss from Hillary what well you
know what they say once you go president
you you come back all right moving on
[Music]
code base cases cami Lee for code babes
comm code let's learn to code for you're
having trouble paying attention welcome
to your solution oh all the other sites
offer the same [ __ ] we take gamification
to the next level after a real positive
feedback like Pavlov's dog on crack she
said [ __ ] this must be legit babes and
codes you watch the lesson absorb the
info pass the quiz and then you jerk-off
miss doctor who's one piece of clothing
oh my [ __ ] god that's genius so join
a couple ridiculous and hot code babes
and start your web development career
today
oh my or just watch I don't even care
about coding I get select which one do
you want to want to learn the Android
version yeah I'll go with the Android
version I think thank you very much for
fancy badass text editor with a
bajillion features to make programming
easier activity is just how Android
refers to the difference the [ __ ] is she
taking her clothes I don't go to
configure an SDK manager and install
everything checked there it's always
great to learn stuff from people who
have no idea what the [ __ ] they're
talking about activity is just how
Android refers the difference I really
that really inspires me to learn because
there's really passion behind the words
I love sushi I love Japan
period oh my god I've seen this one I've
seen this one a very long time ago it's
so [ __ ] good
oh my god this is real I had never
watched part B on this part
[Applause]
I would love to be that person I would
love to be that person so much people
are just randomly talking about stuff
they like oh man this food is so good
and just randomly pop in with a [ __ ]
thing in your hand and gaming I love
this video that's a great [ __ ] video
a really good video
Sonic Heroes Happy Meal and it's in
Pakistan for Sonic can you stop [ __ ]
Sonic he's been [ __ ] enough stop sonic
[Music]
skateboard head of basketball
French people you will cringe beauty
path you will cringe baby bear watch
this last video Minecon 2016 Oh - the
one Ocelot right no okay in character
ever its tail's so good I'm stamping Oh
your step
and was stamping you dumb [ __ ]
[Music]